welcome everyone to the 2 o'clock Sunday
class kids class and we have a lot of
good players today so we're going to
have some good to practice games as well
but first we'll take a look at the game
that I want to show you until we'll move
on to the the practice games as well
also have some tactical puzzles as well
that we will work on but let's take a
look at this very important line okay of
the Queens gambit declined so as soon as
black plays the move e6 here
that's a Queens gambit Queens gambit
declined because he declined he didn't
accepted it if you take up this way this
would have been called accept it okay
now we play Knight c3 now here black has
two options black and play Knight f6 and
the decline or you can buy Bishop e7
there are some other options as well
okay if he plays Bishop e7 that's to
stop Bishop g5 we'll talk about that as
well first we'll talk about 9 f6
now you take he takes and now you want
to try to pin it pin it to win it
remember we talked about that what do
you mean by saying pin it yes that is
pinning it now my question to you is
black plays the move Knight B d7 and it
looks like you just blunder the pawn
right if we take this pawn he takes we
take the Queen and we're winning the
Queen it looks like a blunder by black
but can you calculate deeper here to see
in fact if it is a blunder or maybe not
raise your hand if you finish
calculating and you have an idea
can black tick you can white take that
pawn on d5 and have a good position can
he do that okay this is the liner argent
mentioned 95 it's actually a blunder by
poor white because after he takes Bishop
takes Queen check and now suddenly King
is chopped now he has to go here and we
take and at the end of the line block is
the one actually now upper piece because
you managed to win them the knight on d5
you have three minor pieces versus two
okay
dream minor pieces versus two so that's
why we don't want to take on d5 we play
III now he played c6 you develop the
Bishop to d3 Bishop e7 9 GE 2 this is
the better setup in my opinion you can
also play this lines with Knight f3 but
I like Knight g2 lines better because
you have more attacking chances castles
Queen c2
rocky eight castles Knight f8 now he
plays Knight f8 and now you will play
this move f3 okay the plan the idea
behind f3 is to play E for and remember
this the one of the most famous games
played in this line is the game between
Kasparov vs. barua okay so the Kasparov
vs. barois game now your model game
should be that game okay for this one so
you can take a look at that game later
on you can find a game online so
Kasparov won the game very nicely with
white so I will show you a few more
moves on this line now Knight g6 is
played by black and now let me ask you a
question do you think white is ready to
start the attack do you think white is
ready to start the attack or maybe
there's something else needs to be done
yes
aha yes you still have to develop the
rooks
well one rook in particular okay the one
rook in particular you want to develop
the roof on f1 okay
so where do you want to put that rook
the rook where do you think the best
Square is for that rook yes f2 this one
and then you want to bring the other one
you could but it's kind of you want to
double up the rooks when the file is
already open okay yes yes
C or D D that's the square you want to
put the repeater because you want to
support okay support your Center okay
when you play E for you want to have the
center protected now very interesting
move H six attacking the bishop now
Bishop is under attack
now Bishop is under attack now what can
you do
Bishop is under attack what can you do
the question is if you retreat now on f4
he takes it if you bring it to h4 he
takes it so you're going to do something
about it
but what yes excellent thinking take the
knight correct decision he takes back
now you lost one of your bishops for a
knight now and also your pawn is hanging
on e3 the next few moves is a little bit
not clear why white is playing like that
giving up his bishops but he's got an
idea now what is the another move you
have here good move to create some
weaknesses which move will create some
weaknesses for black yes
excellent thinking Tex
now do you want to take this pawn do you
but you're ready to lose your good pan
for the weak pawn if you take this I
take you trouble for you because I lost
I took your good pan and you took my
double pawn and you don't have center
anymore so don't do that okay
don't do that now you have a very
important move you have to play this
whole concept his whole concept and
ideas is based based on this move it's
based on this move
what is the move here you're going to
play what is the move that we are going
to play here losing the pawn again I do
not want to lose my pawn only three it's
important for me not to lose the plan
okay what else you can do okay what else
you can do with this pawn you're going
to lose this right yes you could go to
b3 yes but then some Bishop a5 idea
stick run not so clear what else you can
do what else you can do yes he's got an
excellent pawn to e4 very good yes you
push the pawn and you're ready to push
it again okay you want to push this pawn
forward that's a passed pawn and if it
takes it you take back and now you got
one to two defenders on this so this is
very important you have a rook here
because you have a defender okay now
he plays g5 he doesn't want to take
because if we take panties it's very
strong septic g5 now what is the idea
yes Bishop to e7
excellent yes that's the plan B 5 and F
for now you want to play f5 f6 to
conduct a very strong attack now he
takes it now you're going to take back
but my question to you is how you want
to capture this back a lot of hands I
see yes with the rook or with the night
you could deck with the rook the only
thing is you may attack you with the
bishop now and then you have to move it
away so it's not so clear okay it's not
so clear so we prefer to take with
Knight and now look at the square now
look at this week square now you have
that you can jump in into it again the
model game is Kasparov Barua rook f8 and
now there is a weak Square right what
are we going to do to that weak square
now in the back yes excellent 96 putting
pressure putting pressure on this very
good now he takes check X now he goes
Bishop e6
now you would need to maneuver maneuver
your piece to put pressure where you're
going to maneuver this piece one on one
of your pieces is not doing that much
work right now it could be improved
which piece I'm referring to you think
which this which piece could be improved
here okay I see a lot of hands good
which piece I'm referring to excellent
Archer very good where are you going to
move this night to improve to better
location okay perfect
very good think an excellent night e to
night where for that's what you want to
do okay that's where you want to go with
this Queen d7 and now yes Knight to f4
perfect now attacking the bishop only
six and now if he makes this attacking
attempt with Bishop f5 it's just going
to be a blunder why is this a blunder do
you see why is this a blunder yes check
look at that
you're not only winning one you winning
two to pieces okay everybody got this so
this is your ideal position okay and
you're going to take the bishop on e6
and have a nice advantage if you happen
to play Bishop a5 it's going to be a big
blunder and you will win the game fund
yes you have a question here
well you're up two pieces here the way
you would finish this off sure I will
show you the way you finish the surface
you want to just advance your pawn and
queen
okay so let's say he plays here right
let's say he does that now you push this
guy here now the easiest way to win is
push push fixing it now getting the
square for this and now who's going to
show me the checkmate in two idea here
who is going to show me that finishing
touch here
think about it one two one two you have
here one two because of that night on g6
now you're going to be able to find the
checkmate you finally see it excellent
good go first of all all you're going
for more material you could do that you
could go for more material but I would
like to I would like to actually go for
a mate
instead of material I want mate - who is
gonna put a mating net here to make it
work here absolutely move the rook up
and now he does whatever he does here he
takes your knight
what you going to do what do you say and
what is this checkmate correct yes yes
yeah we could he could just play this
one we had delay it he could it wouldn't
really help that much but yeah he just
delays it you're right in fact it [ __ ]
it's going to be a checkmate okay well
excellent job this is a very strong
class here very good now we're going to
do one puzzle before one
özil before we move on to the practice
games and here I want you to play like a
world champion okay
Borel champion here let's see if you can
play like a bull of champion number
three kappa blanka let's see if you can
find this tactic okay why to play I
don't want you to say your answers I
will give you two minutes to think and
then I want you to raise your hands
don't raise your hands now you see the
clock in two minutes raise your hand
right now think white to play checkmate
you need to find a quick way to
checkmate here I'm not saying how many
moves but it's a quick path to the
victory play like a world champion here
kappa blanka now let's think it two
moves the two minutes thinking two
minutes thinking before you raise your
hand remember you still have a minute
and so double-check your answer
double check your answer or you want to
take this guy
rook h7 Queen on F Quinn on c8 Queen
takes Knight check that's correct
Wow it's good excellent congratulations
yes you found it correct very good good
job yes so this idea is called removing
the defender removing the guard remember
that
removing the guard got it so you take on
f8 he takes and then you go for the
checkmate all right excellent let's do
one more before we move on to the
practice games okay this one is a little
bit harder it's not a maid it's winning
the material position okay it's winning
the material white to play and win
you're just going to win the game okay
not we're not trying to mate this okay
if we take his knight we lose our abyss
so looks like we are in trouble but
actually we're not we are not we have a
move we have a very very powerful move
here that we can try to play that's very
nice move here because he does have that
escape square that we call it lift but
it's the color of your Bishop so that
should give you some ideas to think
about to to think about to what's the
move here to make sure he doesn't escape
that easily okay what is the movie or
yes correct answer Bishop d3 now he will
take you what are you going to do now he
takes you now take back we can take back
the best way to take back is to make him
here do you see it see it and what do
you say checkmate here you got it
excellent yes now but one more question
one more question to you guys if it goes
rook e8 and defending the knight now it
looks like he defended it not a big
problem
but there is over workpiece here what
you're going to do now to take advantage
of the overworked piece which is the
rook on e8 you know okay
correct he takes back check check
checkmate excellent okay very good so
Bishop d3 it's not easy move to find you
have to understand the ideas okay yes
what is the question yeah good question
I take the tree now if that happens what
kind of move you can do first before you
capture the knight back in between move
okay in between mafias check and the
tech and you're up a whole rook all rook
up here okay okay well well yeah it's a
little bit yeah it's it I agree with you
it's better than getting checkmate
indefinitely but again the outcome of
this game should be a victory for white
because of the extra rook okay oh yeah
yeah you could say that yes okay now we
have about 20 minutes so I'm going to
match you up with the people around your
strengths and so we'll play some good
matchups now